hello and we're glad you've joined us
for this live webinar measuring single
EVs and their cargo sensitive and
specific vesicle flow cytometry I'm Suzy
Valdez of Lavery's and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab routes the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by Beckman Coulter
life sciences to learn more about our
sponsor please visit them at WWF Ekman
comm so let's get started
you can pose questions to the speaker
during the presentation while they're
fresh in your mind to do so simply type
them into the drop down box located on
the far left of your screen labeled ask
a question and click that send button
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the arrows the top right hand
corner of the presentation window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing this presentation simply click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by typing it into
the answer a question box located on the
far left of your screen this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education credit
tab located at the top right of the
presentation window and follow the
process for obtaining your credits I now
present today's speaker dr. John Nolan a
professor at the scintillant
Institute a nonprofit Research Institute
and he's the past director of the
National flow cytometry resource that
was Alma welcome dr. Nolan you may now
begin your presentation welcome sir
well good morning and thanks for
inviting me to give this webinar and
it's my pleasure to tell you today a
little bit about measuring single EVs
and their cargo using vesicle closed eye
tama tree my name is John Nolan I'm a
professor at the cinta LAN Institute
where my group develops new tools for
selling molecular analysis including
extracellular vesicle analysis we work
collaboratively with both academic and
industrial researchers to address
important problems in vesicle analysis
and we're part of a multi lab
international working group looking to
standardize and optimize the analysis of
individual vesicles by flow cytometry
we're also involved in commercializing
some of the technologies I'm going to
talk about today the Salukis Biosciences
and we're working with Beckman Coulter
who's our sponsor today so today I'm
going to tell you a little bit about
exercise the vesicles where they come
from and what they do I'll talk about
how they're analyzed conventionally and
some of the challenges and opportunities
for using quote cytometry to analyze
extracellular vesicles and then I'll
describe our approach to measuring
vesicles single vesicle flow cytometry
so it's appreciated now that all cells
release vesicles carrying molecular
cargo into the extracellular space if
one reads one of the many review
articles that are published almost
weekly one will find that these are
often classed into a couple categories
of vesicles exosomes which are generated
inside the cell and released by
secretion micro vesicles that are but
directly from the surface of the
membrane in reality it's probably a bit
more complicated than this but the end
result is is that the extracellular
space will be populated by these small
nanoparticles carrying molecular cargos
that cargo can travel to interact with
nearby or distant selves can interact
with cell surface receptors be taken up
into the cells and have effects on the
recipient cell and so it's a great
interest to understand both how vesicles
are made what happens when they reach a
target cell and the key to that is
understanding what the cargo is of these
individual vesicles so this is going to
be our focus today is how to
characterize these vesicles in in a bio
fluid because understanding the features
of these vesicles at the individual
level understanding their cargo is going
to be key to developing diagnostic
biomarkers or potentially therapeutics
because presumably it's the cargo that
these vesicle carries that carry that
biological information
this is a fairly simplified version of
vesicles released from cells a recent
review article expanded on this a bit
and indicate now indicates the diversity
of different nanoparticles that can be
released by cells which vary greatly in
both their size and their molecular
content moreover if one looks into a
complex bio fluid like plasma one sees
lots of other nanoparticles for example
lipoproteins are quite abundant in blood
and other bio bio fluids only fall into
the same size range as vesicles and so
are recognized as a potential
contaminant of vesicle studies or
interesting target all on their own
so this is the challenge to measure
these vesicles in a bio fluid and today
most vesicle analysis approaches start
with some sort of isolation procedure we
need to somehow rich or purify vesicles
from all of those other particles and
there's a range of different methods
that you will find in the literature the
most popular as tabulated by the Eevee
tract consortium which is attempting to
track different vesicle preparation
methods our centrifugation methods
probably half of the published
literature involves centrifugation but
there are other approaches peg
precipitation various filtration
approaches size exclusion or ion
exchange chromatography but whichever
method one considers using it's
important to realize that all of these
fractionation approaches change the
sample right each produces a different
factor of enrichment or recovery or
purity and you know will change your
sample so it's important
keep that in mind and in general our
philosophy is less is more when it comes
to sample processing once we've isolated
or rich our vesicles question comes -
how to characterize them and we'll
categorize these in two buckets one is
the conventional bulk biochemical
analysis these would include Western
blot and Eliza methods for measuring
protein PCR or next-gen sequencing for
genomic analysis etc it's important to
remember that all of these methods
report the average value of a sample and
to illustrate here we'll just walk
through a common vesicle analysis
procedure this one illustrated from
field
Barry's lab has done very seminal
working in the field a multi-step
centrifugation procedure followed by
some analysis of particle size perhaps
by electron microscopy and then an
analysis of the vesicle cargo here using
a Western blot and you can see that
we're looking at some tetris Fannin's
which are thought to be a canonical
marker of certain types of vesicles as
well as some other markers and so when
apply to a mixed sample vesicles like we
might find in a culture supernatant or
in a plasma fraction will will generate
essentially a catalogue of all of the
cargo in that vesicle preparation and
can use that to
a picture of an average vesicle which is
a useful concept to sort of organize our
thoughts but this concept has a
limitation and then is that the average
vesicle doesn't exist that is both
biochemical analysis that reports the
average or total content of a
subtraction aidid sample doesn't tell
the whole story in fact what we would
like to know is what are the different
types of vesicles in that sample as
defined by their size and cargo and to
tabulate these different types of
vesicles and so to do this we need
single vesicle analysis we need to
analyze each vesicle as an individual to
get this information and so turning now
to single vessel single particle
analysis methods we have of course
electron microscopy which might be
considered the gold standard cryo am
being particularly notable for non
perturbing to the structure of the
vesicle however its e/m is fairly non
quantitative and it's slow and
labor-intensive a few other methods that
I'll talk about briefly here include
nano particle tracking analysis and
resistible spectroscopy and then I'll
spend most of our time talking about
flow cytometry so MTA and RPS are two
popular methods to measure single
nanoparticles in case of NGA individual
particles are detected by light scatter
from a laser and then the motion of
those particles are tracked by imaging
methods and the size of the vesicles is
estimated from how fast they diffuse
so this has the advantage of directly
estimating particle diameter from
physical properties and it doesn't
require any labeling to measure so those
are nice the downsides of NTA is that
it's relatively nonspecific that is any
particle that scatters light will be
detected not just vesicles and that the
sensitivity of the message is limited by
how much light those particles can
scatter furthers though there's no real
way to measure cargo on individual
vesicles using MTA a tends to be fairly
low throughput resistive pulse
spectroscopy or RPS can be thought of as
the Coulter principle using nano part
fours there's a current flowing through
a nano poor membrane and when vesicle
enters those pores it will block the
current and that current blockage will
tell you that there was a particle there
in the side of the current blockage
tells you something about the size of
the particle so this again estimates and
counts vesicles an estimate size based
on physical principles it's also labeled
free the downside again is that it's
relatively nonspecific any particle that
passes through the four will generate a
signal pores have the annoying
feature of occasionally blocking which
can make them harder to deal with
there's really no way to measure cargo
using RPS and again it's not a high
throughput method so these methods are
useful but they have limited use for our
purposes of analyzing individual
vesicles and their cargo that brings us
to flow cytometry so why shouldn't we
use flow cytometry you already know it
that makes sensitive measurements of
individual particles there's lots of
protocols and standards for helping us
to measure cells we can do assays
without wash steps often there are
robots and automation that can
facilitate analysis and it's widely
deployed in research labs and clinical
labs so what's the problem
problem is the vesicles aren't cells
they're much much smaller than selves
orders of magnitude smaller and that
means that they're going to produce much
much dimmer signals most conventional
flow cytometry that were designed to
measure cells really lack the
sensitivity to do a good job of
measuring vesicles and the conventional
way people use flow cytometry lacks
specificity and that result of these
limitations is then overall pretty poor
reproducibility for vesicle measurements
and some of the reasons are illustrated
in this on this slide so in a Cell
analysis experiment one might have one
has a large cell which you know is easy
to detect and then if we're interested
in for example surface cargo surface
markers on a cell
those may range in abundance from very
high abundance markers that might be
present at hundreds of thousands of
copies per cell I'm down to low
abundance but perhaps important
molecules that maybe there's only a few
thousand copies per cell but these can
often still be measured by flow
cytometry if we consider a vesicle
released from that same cell
cargo will be much much less and so on
the left here we have a typical size
distribution vesicles collected from
Culture Media say and even for a high
abundance surface marker one can see
that we might have fewer than 100 copies
per vesicle which is already going to
challenge the sensitivity of many
commercial instruments and if we are
considering low or moderate abundance
surface markers those are going to be
even lowered to the point that we might
need to be detecting single molecules so
this is up this is a big challenge for
flow cytometry technology but people
it's both technologies of powerful
technology so people are trying and as
people carefully examine flow cytometry
measurements of vesicles we identify a
number of artifacts that can confound
our analysis most of these artifacts
related to the mistaken identity of
vesicles that is particles that are not
vesicles are mistaken for vesicles and
these could include particulates that
have just happened to be in buffer or
sample it could be particulates that are
in some reagent for instance
preparations of fluorescent antibodies
often contain antibody aggregates or in
the case where your vesicles are too
small and dim to detect which case you
wouldn't be able to detect them if you
have a very high concentration of those
particles such that you have many
particles in the probe volume of the
instrument in the laser beam you can
mistake those multiple vesicles for a
single vesicle and that's referred to as
the coincidence or sworn artifact where
you think you're measuring a single
vesicle but you're really measuring
so you know careful work by many groups
says you know made these artifacts
parents and they've been reported and
several years ago a group of us who were
interested in both flow cytometry and
vesicles got together to start comparing
notes and our goal was obviously
initially to find out the best method to
measure vesicles when we started talking
we realized that we weren't even talking
the same language that is we each use
different instruments we use them in
different ways
we reported our results differently and
so it was actually very hard to compare
across labs and so we took a step back
and took a year or so to develop a set
of guidelines for how one should report
what you did and so this was published
just in the last couple months in the
Journal of extracellular vesicle and
this is intended to complement the
existing guidelines documents in the
field which include my flow site which
tells us what we should report about a
flow cytometry experiment myself which
tells us what we should report about
extracellular vesicles experiment and
this focus is really on issues
associated with flow cytometry of
extracellular vesicles and this is laid
out in some detail in in the manuscript
and there's a series of educational
programs that's going on to to to
disseminate these guidelines I'll just
touch on them briefly I'm here now to
point out that of these guidelines are
some of them refer to the instrument
which is important the performance
features of the instrument and how you
use it are important for your ability to
measure vesicles but it also describes
the larger asset right so an instrument
is not an SI an SI is
as an instrument plus all of the sample
preparation the experimental design the
standards and controls and data analysis
that goes into a measurement so it's
important to keep in mind it's the essay
that we have to be most concerned about
of which an instrument is an important
part of the essay and just to illustrate
a little further just with the issue of
how one uses a flow cytometry to detect
a vesicle
opens us up for a lot of decisions in
you know
flow cytometry 101 we learned that
forward angle light scatter is a measure
of particle size and side scatter is a
measure of particle granularity in
reality neither of these is true but for
cells it's a simplifying useful
approximation and most cell analysis
uses forward scatter forward angle light
scatter to trigger detection when people
try to measure vesicles
flow cytometry light scatter is is not
always the best test best used to of a
detection trigger and some have pointed
out that side scatter might actually be
a more effective trigger for small
particles however both scatter
parameters have the limitation that
they're relatively nonspecific so a
number of investigators have you know
pointed out the advantages of using the
fluorescence channels to trigger
detection and you know with fluorescence
one could use fluorescently labeled
antibody in which case you would detect
the particles that stained with that
antibody or one can use more generic
stains such as a membrane stain or a
cytoplasmic stain to detect you know
vesicles by their surface or
intracellular content and so we
considered and tried you know all of
these approaches and we came to the
conclusion that membrane fluorescence
offered the best opportunity for
sensitive and specific vesicle detection
and that's the basis of the essays and
data that I'm going to tell you about
next
I mentioned the important of instruments
and assays to measuring vesicles and so
today I'm going to tell you about an
assay that uses the Beckman Coulter
saito flex the Saito flex was one of the
first commercial instruments to use a
new generation of photo detectors that
are much more sensitive than the
conventional PMT's used in most
commercial instruments the side effects
has a very clever optical design that
allows it to do a very good job of
collecting light multiple laser options
giving us a range of excitation
wavelengths for probe excitation and a
plate loader which is very nice for
doing standardized essays in 96-well
plates so we use the side effects we
have a couple of them it's a workhorse
for us and it's a workhorse for an assay
let's describe down the right side of
the screen which recalling vesicle flow
cytometry vesicle flow cytometry employs
a vesicle scheme VF red follows a set of
qualified and validated antibodies
appropriate calibration standards and
standardized analysis and data and data
sample processing and data analysis
protocols that allow reproducible
analysis here's an overview of the VF
CSA it's a simple four-step essay
there's a upfront dilution which is
typically determined in some preliminary
experiments to present the sample at the
right concentration for the essay that
sample is stained with our membrane dye
VF red plus one or more antibodies to TV
cargo
after staining the sample is diluted and
then measured on sensitive flow Saitama
we use the red fluorescence from the
membrane stain to trigger detection and
then we measure the immunofluorescence
of any membrane particles that we detect
after we collected data we calibrate the
data so we can express the membrane
fluorescence in terms of a particle size
and we can present the
immunofluorescence in terms of molecules
of antibody detected and so a few points
that are worth making here for this
assay so it measures the Eevee's
directly in a bio fluids of no isolation
or purification is required it provides
membrane selective detection via the
membrane probe and it's a homogeneous a
say there are no wash steps involved on
a sensitive instrument like the side
effects we estimate the size detection
limit is about 70 to 80 nanometers and
conservatively the cargo limit of
detection is about 25 molecules of
antibody per particle
I mentioned that standards are an
important part of any quantitative essay
and we've developed several standards
that are useful for measuring vesicles
the first is a synthetic vesicle size
standard so this is synthetic vesicle
that's been prepared to a uniform size
distribution and contains a liquid
composition that's comparable to a
mammalian cell and we use this to
calibrate our vfc size measurements and
we also use this as a negative control
for needle fluorescent since it has no
antigens on it we use beads as well
we have fluorescence intensity beads
nano rainbow beads that have been cross
calibrated against mes F type standards
so that fluorescence can be reported in
quantitative terms we also have
developed some antibody capture beads
that are calibrated in terms of their
antibody binding capacity and these are
also useful for calibrating
immunofluorescence finally we are
developing cell derived DVS that can
serve as standards or reference
materials which are especially useful
for immunofluorescence as I'll describe
on here in a little bit and so we've
configured these standards and reagents
into an assay kit and a series of
protocols that help the user get
interprete balandin to scible
information and so I'll walk I'll walk
you through now a typical workflow
setting up to do a PFC measurement the
jeweler circles so first off we need to
test the instrument and make sure it's
tuned up and ready to go
and that it has the sensitivity we need
and it is calibrated to allow
quantitative recording and so here the
Nano rainbow beads our first sample
these beads are multi pique multi floor
for beads so they'll fluoresce in many
channels and we use these to do several
things we use them to assess whether all
of our lasers are properly aligned we
allow we use these to evaluate the
sensitivity of each of our channel so
for example in the VF red channel where
we're going to do our detection and size
measurements we can use a separation
index or staining index metric to
evaluate the performance of an
instrument over on the
immunofluorescence channel because we've
calleb callebaut eight of these and
units of mes f/4 mean equivalent soluble
fluorochromes we can use these to
calibrate our immunofluorescence
channels the beads are also present at a
known particle concentration so that we
can use these to validate the sample
flow rates of the instrument and so
there's a some protocols and analysis
layouts that I wanted to do this in the
show QC and to qualify an instrument as
ready to do vfc measurement once we've
done that we will prepare and stain our
samples and here we have a couple of
different protocols that are used in a
typical study first is to do a series of
serial solutions so we can assess the SI
dynamic range measure the Eevee
concentration and determine the best
solution for subsequent studies also to
make sure we don't have that coincidence
or a swarm artifact that I'll get to
before
and once we've set up those features of
the sample dilution then we can move
ahead and do Eevee counting sizing and
cargo analysis with PFC and so the
protocols for doing those are well
standardized and laid out and easy to
follow away with plate maps that guide
the user and ensure that all of the
necessary positive and negative controls
are done so the important controls to
consider with the create a buffer only
control and reagent only control as
negative controls if we're doing in you
know fluorescence we're going to have
with and without antibody controls
ideally we have a positive control for
the SI and so you know this this leads
itself to a standardized assay protocol
which is illustrated on plate map on the
right
staining the samples are diluted the
final dilution after staining is a
thousandfold because the plates have a
limited volume the wells of the plate
set a limited volume we actually do that
dilution in two steps so on the far
right of the plate indicates the stain
the diluted samples that are actually
going to be run in the protocol and so
these are all laid out step by step to
promote reproducibility and ease of use
and then once we've collected our data
we need to process it and again the data
analysis needs to be standardized in
order to be reproducible and we use FCS
Express as our analysis platform which
has a number of attractive features for
enabling a standardised analysis
protocol so typically the gating
sequence they're presented on the Left
panel includes a little bit of time
gating to avoid any fluidic disturbances
that might happen at the beginning of a
sample which is a common common feature
in flow measurements so we gate on the
hundreds hundred seconds of data
acquisition you set a gate on the pulse
shape parameters of the VF red dye so
when one is working close to the limit
of detection of an instrument it's
possible to use the signal pulse height
area and width to discriminate between
real events and various sources of
background and so that's a gating step
that we use and then finally we set a
gate based on our membrane stain and
light scatter which again can help us
identify vesicles that have
characteristic fluorescence and light
scatter and eliminate certain types of
background that might
be distinguishable based on their light
scatter so that's the gating that
leads us to identify which particles are
vesicles and then we use some of the
data processing capabilities or FCS
Express to calibrate our measurements we
convert the membrane fluorescence into
an estimated size we measure the the
light scatter and then we measure each
of the fluorescent signals and we
present those data in calibrated units
whenever possible of molecules per
particle so the data analysis is is also
very standardized and straightforward
let me discuss some of these essential
controls that are necessary to avoid
some of the common artifacts the first
one I described was the dilution series
this is just taking a sample and doing a
set of twofold serial dilutions and
confirming that the
particles detected decreases with
pollution but that the the distribution
the fluorescents are light scattered
distributions of those don't change with
pollution these are what wasn't it
expect if when we're truly measuring
individual particles so this is a
important important control that's going
to do another useful control is to show
that the particles you detected our
detergent labile membrane particles like
vesicles should dissolve when detergent
is added and so this detergent treatment
control is another one that is highly
recommended to show that what you've
detected our our vesicles next a couple
words about Eevee size and light scatter
as I mentioned we use a synthetic like
lipid vesicle that you know resembles a
extracellular vesicle as a size standard
we measure its size by those orthogonal
methods like nga and RPS and then when
we measure the fluorescence of those
vesicles stained with our beef red dye
we find that there's a nice linear
relationship between membrane surface
area and membrane fluorescence as might
be expected so one can use the membrane
fluorescence to estimate size which is
the safe surface area if you have an
estimate of surface area you can
calculate diameter just using geometry
and assuming that these are spherical
particles which which we do we also
measure light scatter light scatter is
not the best method to detect vesicles
because it's relatively nonspecific but
it does provide a lot of useful
information it's you know related to
size but also perhaps more importantly
refractive index and so as an
interesting example different vesicles
from different cell types can have
different amounts of light scatter in
this diagram where
comparing our synthetic lipid vesicles
with some bicycles isolated from
platelets and from red cells and one can
see that they differ in their amount of
light scatter and thus likely saying
telling us something about the cargo and
the effect of that cargo on the particle
refractive index we do these assays in
96 well plates which makes it
straightforward to do things like assess
the reproducibility of the SI and here
are some quadruplicate measurements of
our various vesicle standard showing
that the reproducibility is very good so
now I've been focusing mostly on size
and counting but the reason most of us
want to use both cytometry is so we can
use fluorescence to measure evey cargo
and so here I'll just make a couple
comments on immunofluorescence of EVs
and so some of this will be obvious that
people are used to doing closed
cytometry but if you come from a
perspective where your most enduring
Western blots it's it's useful to
consider so in a typical
immunofluorescence measurement will of
course have negative controls those are
important and so we use a couple
different types of negative controls
depending on the situation
our lipo 100 synthetic lipid vesicles
serves as a negative control because it
only has a membrane with no antigen and
isotype control is also a useful control
to detect for instance how much of your
staining might be due to binding to the
FC receptor present on a vesicle on a
form of nonspecific binding and in our
for our purposes it's always nice to
have a positive control and so for any
target that we measure we like to
identify a positive control for CD 9 a
common Tetris fan it's very abundant on
platelet v's
and so here we see you know a perfect
case where almost all of the vesicles
detected are clearly identified as CD 9
positive there's no no problem calling
the vesicle positive or negative here
but if we consider another tetris Bannon
for example CD 81 which is abundant heck
2 9 3 cells we see this like a different
distribution right we see a case where
there's clearly some positive vesicles
but also clearly some negative s achill
and so one can you know put a gate or a
marker to identify the number of
vesicles that are positive and the
vesicles that are negative but if one
considers CD 9 on those same two nine
three V's a different type of staining
here it appears that they're all a
little bit positive but they are not so
positive that they're clearly resolved
from the unstaged peak and so in this
case you know even though one might have
placed a marker for positivity it would
be you know inaccurate to describe this
population is having some percent
positive since it's clear that there's
only one population that is sort of
dimly positive so it's important to keep
in mind the diversity of staining
behavior that one might find looking for
surface markers on extracellular
vesicles all of the practices from
Sall immunofluorescence will apply to
ethical immunofluorescence including the
need to titrate all your reagents in
fact it's probably even more important
for vesicle measurement since we are not
doing a wash step we're only doing a
dilution step and so having those
antibody reagents carefully titrated so
it's not produce high background is also
important so all of the all of the
measurements I'll talk about have been
through such optimization um
I mentioned earlier that you know our
Eevee standards or reference
preparations are very useful for
optimizing and validating
immunofluorescence and here tools like
immuno gold cry OEM can be used to help
validate our standards so got our red
cells arrive standards and our
platelet-derived standards and we can
stain those with platelets specific
markers CD 41 in this case or a red cell
specific marker CD 235 like or foreign
and show that the red cells stain with
the red cell marker and platelets stain
the platelet marker on both of them show
a little bit of staining to an X + 5
which measures procoagulant
phosphatidylserine present on the cell
our vesicle surface and we can you know
confirm the specificity of that staining
using cryo am an immuno gold
so with that background on the mechanics
validation vfc I'll wrap up here by
describing some measurements we made and
some of the insights that gives us into
evey diversity so Texas Fannin's are
popular a target to measure in vesicles
they play an important role in
organization of the membrane and it's
been suggested that you know you should
measure Tetris tannins in your ethical
prep which leads to the question which
which touches Fannin should you measure
CD 963 and 81 are the most popular
methods man if one looks in the
literature will one will generally find
a western blot with one or more those
tested for but actually there's nearly
twenty Tetris tannins known including
some others that are fairly frequent and
so you know a question we thought to ask
is what does vfc tell us about Tetris
pain in expression and so through our
internal work and collaborations you had
an opportunity to screen a number of
different cell lines and cell types or
vesicles from those cell lines for type
to span and expression so here's a a
panel that shows the staining of those
three canonical tetris bands 963 and 81
plus some of the other Tetris payments
across a whole range of vesicles from
different cell types anyone can just
observe quite a diversity in staining
behavior including cases where one
Tetris painting predominates for a cell
type to cases where multiple tetris
bands are expressed but also cases where
it's clear that there are some vesicles
that express no tetris paintings all
was all the diversity that one can
imagine in terms of cargo expression you
know can be observed if one measures
enough different samples and so if we
just take one number from these these
measurements and so we're going to
measure the median fluorescence
intensity just as approximation of
ethical expression we can sort of
visualize the diversity of texas-pan and
expression amongst these different cell
types and see that not only does the
ratio of different types of fans vary
but the absolute abundance of number per
vesicle also varies and so in this data
tells us that instead of Petrus tannins
being thought of as a universal marker
of EVs
that's not the case at all right there's
clearly some vesicles that don't have
any tetris Fannin's and the type of
tester Sandlin varies greatly depending
on cell type but the set row span in
profile might be a distinguishing
feature of a certain type of vesicle
from a certain cell type and so there's
a lot of information to be contained to
be obtained from just studying the
tetris Fannin's that one can extend this
then to other site types of surface
markers integrins tumor markers etc and
that's that's what we're doing finally
I'll wrap up by talking about measuring
these samples directly in bio fluids
such as plasma and at the top of the
talk I pointed out that plasma has lots
of other stuff in it besides vesicles
lots of proteins but also lots of
nanoparticles particularly lipoproteins
and lipoproteins will stain with our
membrane stain because they are
essentially limited by a lipid mono
layer
however because they have a different
composition they have different
refractive indices and scatter
differently and so using the multi
parameter capabilities we can actually
resolve vesicles from other non
vesicular structures and so in this
demonstration we've stained our vesicles
or our plasma not only with VF red but
also with CF se which can stain the
internal volume of certain vesicles and
we've stained these with a mix of those
three tetrus tannins and so by using
multi parameter analysis with
multicolored bec gating we can see where
the vesicles that stained CF se in
Petrus bannon's fall on a plot of size
versus light scatter and use this to
identify vesicles even in a very complex
sample like plasma where there's lots of
other potential interference so with
that I'll wrap it up and summarize so
really understanding V's and especially
translating them into biomarkers and
therapeutics it's going to require
knowing about the properties of
individual EBS and so that's why we need
method the single medical resolution
that are quantitative in specific and so
that's what that's the problem we've
tried to solve here with vfc and as i've
demonstrated we can detect the size
vesicles specifically we can measure
their surface marker and then supported
by standards and standardized protocols
we can generate data that's very
reproducible and suitable for comparison
across labs and across
between instruments so with that I'll
close by acknowledging my co-workers and
collaborators and we'll open it up for
any questions
Shen's we will now start the live Q&A
session of the webinar a quick reminder
for our audience on how to submit
questions simply type them into the drop
down box located on the far left in your
presentation window labeled ask a
questions and click on the send button
dr. Nolan will answer as many questions
as time permits all right let's go ahead
and get started your first question we
have here and lots of great questions
what fluorescent dye do you use for the
staining
so the the membrane stain we use is VF
red its formulation of a lipophilic
membrane dye that has the nice property
of being very dim dimly or
non-fluorescent in buffer but getting
very bright when it intercalate tend to
the membrane we tested a lot of dyes
over the years I think it's important to
note that you know the dye is important
but also important is how you use the
dye and so really the most critical part
of the assay is is the use of the dye in
in the protocol thank you very much for
that and would you describe the major
differences in both triggering and size
estimation using side scatter versus the
same using fluorescence
yeah sure so as I mentioned you know the
way people most people start using a
flow cytometer is with is light skater
to Detroit to trigger detection which
works well for large particles small
particles like vesicles don't scatter
nearly as much light as large particles
and often end up very close to the
background noise of a system so there's
intrinsic background noise from light
scatter an instrument and then buffers
and she food can contain particulates
that cause additional scatter background
that can be quite tricky to confidently
detect vesicles against all this
background and you know we tried hard
and that's really what drove us to
develop fluorescence based approaches
and so when we use fluorescence to
trigger detection we don't have really
those same background issues when we try
to use light scatter and as I mentioned
you know put us and let us tomato size
but it also makes light scatter more
useful in a way because when used as a
secondary parameter after fluorescence
triggering it can provide some very
interesting information not only about
size potentially but also about
refractive index which I think has a lot
of potential as a as a distinguishing
feature so they're both useful and you
know really the trick is to how you use
those two parameters thank you for that
and now when I thank our audience
members for their live questions coming
in you have quite a few great questions
coming in dr. going art are you clearly
how you clearly have a lot of experience
across different analytical techniques
for measuring extra-curricular vesicles
have you found one universe
marker that can be used across all easy
detection for measurement or capture so
you know the best we've we've been able
to come up with so far is the membrane
staining which you know will stain
pretty much any vesicle we've tried but
of course people are interested in
identifying molecular surface cargo that
would be a marker of a vesicle surface
cargo or internal cargo for instance
that one can use to detect by a Western
blot for instance and so that's where
the notion that Tetris Fannin's might be
a universal marker because it seems like
most every vesicle preparation showed
some tuchis tannins in a Western blot
but you know what's really interesting
is when you look at the individual
vesicles and find the tetris span and
expression actually vary so greatly
amongst different types of vesicles so
you know as a universal marker Tetris
bannon's
you know aren't going to be it but on
the other hand they are going to provide
I think a lot of interesting information
about where a vesicle came from so that
you know the search is still on for the
magical Universal marker of an Eevee
thank you for that and can the kit use
to determine the sensitivity of
conventional FC instrument to decide if
it's worth working or optimizing on it
right so I know that's a question lots
of people have can is my instrument
sensitive enough to measure these and
you know calibration will provide the
answer for that
so for vesicle size we use our LIPA's
ohms with the VF red stain and our nano
rainbow beads to
judge that an instrument is going to
have the necessary sensitivity to detect
the vesicles and then over on the
immunofluorescence side one can use you
know available calibration reagents to
estimate what your limit of detection
would be for surface cargo
so yes beads beans can help you make a
judgment about how sensitive your flow
cytometer is and whether it's going to
be useful to measure small dim particles
like vesicles thank you for that and do
you have any issues with precipitation
of the bf red dye and formation of
background particles causing high
background for EVD TV detection um not
as not when performed according to the
protocol so handled with with the
formulation and handled according to the
protocol VF red will give you know very
low backgrounds in buffer only type
controls and you know clear detection of
vesicles when present thank you for that
and what are the levels of mes F of the
Nano rainbow beads so when we when we do
the cross calibration those beads range
from a few tens of molecules M ESF's to
a couple of thousand which is sort of
the range we would expect to see in
vesicles of this size stained with an
antibody for instance thank you and what
is the contract of easy recommend to
avoid saturation of
for example Saito flex alright so
there's a quick comes to you know
determining the you know optimal input
concentration you know what sort of
dilution you should apply to your sample
before you measure that we aim for a
detection of fifty thousand events in a
hundred microliters of diluted sample so
every well is analyzed for a hundred and
twenty seconds we take the final 100
seconds which is equivalent to one
hundred microliters of analyzed sample
and we aim for fifty thousand events in
a typical reagent holding or buffer only
control we might have a couple of
thousand events so the mid-range of our
dynamic range would be about fifty
thousand events our limit of detection
on the low end is might put it at about
five thousand events and on the upper
end we can go up to about five hundred
thousand events before we start seeing
evidence of coincidence which can happen
at high concentrations so typically I
say has about a two-fold 100 fold
dynamic range and that's a few thousand
events corresponds to about five times
ten to the six vesicles per microliter
so that's a that's a good target
concentration to consider and definitely
protein aggregates will also separate a
pond detergent treatment one will need
I'm sorry let me skip that question how
many easy counts do you need to receive
statistically relevant data and
approximately how much time does it take
for one sample right
so just to clarify on the last answer so
every every sample runs for two minutes
we're running at the high sample flow
rate on the Saito flex which is about a
micro liter per second so two minutes
per well um and in a buffer only control
we might get a couple thousand counts of
background so you know a confident limit
of detection would be you know perhaps a
couple thousand counts above that and
then as I mentioned at the high end we
can go up to about a half a million
counts in 100 microliters or a hundred
seconds of analysis before we start
seeing signs that the sample is too
concentrated and were getting reports or
other evidence of coincident detection
wonderful and again thank you to our
audience members for their great
questions coming in any questions not
answered today will be answered via
email the other one I've heard that
using SSC off so the violet laser is
better than the blue laser is this true
and if so why so in general the light
scatter from a particle will have
greater be greater sensitivity to small
particles at shorter wavelengths so all
things being equal a violet laser is
theoretically superior to a blue laser
what are the things that can make those
not equal well if you have more power
right so a high-powered blue laser you
know might outperform a weaker powered
violet laser for instance so you know to
maximize light scatter sensitivity you
know one might design an instrument that
had violet light scatter with a pseudo
powerful source which is the case for
the side effects which we are we used
and I talked about today which has no
very nice light scatter sensitivity
thank you for that and what are the
limitations in terms of sample in order
to be able to analyze Vivi's cargo
directly with the form plasma well so in
order to detect specific cargo there
needs to be enough of it present on the
vesicle to detect and vesicles bearing
that cargo need to be you know numerous
enough to be detected against various
sources of other background so in terms
of the sensitivity for
immunofluorescence right now with with
an instrument like the Saito flex at
limit of detection beyond the order of
20 or 25 molecules per vesicle you know
by our estimates in terms of number of
vesicles or concentration a few thousand
per microliter represents sort of a
practical lower limit of detection so as
long as your your vesicles are brighter
than twenty-five molecules of
fluorescence and more abundant and a few
thousand per microliter you should be
able to detect them
in plasma thank you we have time for one
more question
car audience member says first of all
great presentation what level of
filtering is required for buffers i'm
diluent etc to reduce the background so
it never hurts um it never hurts to
filter but as i described when one uses
fluorescence to trigger detection rather
than light scatter the stringencies and
requirements are are much more relaxed
if you're no longer worried about false
triggering from particles background
particles that scatter light and so
actually in for RC fluid
in the side-effects we just use standard
Milly cure water lily cue water without
additional filtering although as I
mentioned filtering doesn't hurt we we
pay extra attention to our dilution
buffers and you know that we make our
samples and reagents in and so we
typically filter all of those buffers
that touch the sample through a twenty
or twenty five nanometer filter to make
sure they're as clean as as possible so
those are our recommendations but like I
said you know cleaner is always better
thank you dr. noha for this presentation
and thank you so much for the important
research that you do before we go I want
to thank the audience member for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions and as a reminder any
questions we haven't had time for today
will be addressed from the speaker via
your contact information you provided at
the time of registration I'd like to
thank labret and our sponsor Beckman
culture life sciences for underwriting
today's educational webcast this webcast
can be viewed on-demand and labrys will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event annex
till next time
buh-bye be safe and take care